[Music]
the new madden game is out today and
there's a mild glitch if you hit the
jump the literal jump cut i mean that is
beyond any super power that any
superhero known to man
can muster there's got to be
like a movie that comes out of this like
there's like who can do that stats
superman can't do that that's the
le'veon bell jump cut in madden i have a
feeling they've fixed that glitch that's
uh look he's he's a very talented player
obviously i think the ravens need to
worry about their gap control
maybe the message is that if he would
show up for training camp in the
pre-season he too could actually do that
during a game you see le'veon you see
what happens when you don't show up for
training camp you can't do a 75-yard
jump cut where you
literally knife through the defense and
over them
how does that happen that would be
infuriating like especially you're
playing you know you're
in a tight game everything's neck and
neck you're into it all of a sudden boom
le'veon bell 50 yards down the field
you know what i did last night you know
i've been i've been doing this ultimate
team i have my ultimate team up to an 81
since i had advanced access to the game
i was playing online
i had the game one right i was up seven
to six
late
field goal range just trying to work the
clock had a third and short and i
decided you know what he knows i'm going
to run it so i'll i'll throw a little
swing pass yeah i was intercepted in
return for a touchdown
good that's what you did i'm still first
about it today good that's ridiculous
yeah
all right should you be doing that i'm
going to get an xbox because i know
you're too cheap to go get a ps4 so i'll
go get an xbox so you and i can play
madden online and i can beat the hell
out of you like i did both times we've
played twice now once a year during the
pft live summit and i'm two and oh so i
expect that to continue poor pith